hey everyone and welcome back to another
video by simply learn today we are
diving into the world of search engine
marketing answering the big question why
is sem important well whether you're a
small business or a Big Brand sem can
significantly boost your online presence
but how does it differ from SEO that is
search engine optimization stick around
and we'll break down the semm versus SEO
debate ever wondered how these ads
magically appear when you search for
something that's sem in action we will
unravel the mystery of how sem works and
explore the tools that make it all
happen curious about add auctions we
have got you covered find out the
Integrity of how businesses bid for
those Prime advertising Sports and of
course no SC journey is complete without
effective campaign strategies join us as
we uncover the secrets of running
successful sem campaigns also if you are
interested in advanced ing your career
consider P University postgraduate
program in digital marketing this
comprehensive program offers
certification as a digital marketer
through live Interactive Learning dive
deep into fundamentals and advanced
digital marketing strategies utilizing
Harvard Business publishing cases and
Hands-On participation in 20 plus
projects access the full spectrum of
digital marketing tools with chat GPT
and AI tools complemented by 35 Plus
dedicated resources all right now let's
move on on to the first topic which is
what is search engine marketing so a
search engine marketing or sem is a
strategy where businesses use paid ads
on search engine results pages scps to
boost visibility typically seen on
Google or Bing sem involves bidding on
keywords relevant to products or
Services when users search with those
keywords ads from successful biders
appear prominently it's like a shortcut
to be seen when people are looking for
something specific online advertisers
pay when someone clicks on their ad
which is known as pay per click that is
PPC the goal is to attract potential
customers actively seeking related
information sem complement search engine
optimization that is SEO efforts by
providing immediate visibility this
Dynamic marketing approach allows
businesses to tailor campaigns measure
performance and adjust strategies
quickly contributing to a more agile and
responsive online presence
all right so this was about search
engine marketing now let's understand
why is it important so with more people
relying on the internet to discover and
buy products search engine marketing has
become a vital for expanding a company's
online presence the majority of new
website visitors come from search engine
queries sem ensures that companies only
pay for ads when they lead to actual
visits making it a costeffective
marketing strategy moreover each
visitors contribut Utes to improving a
website's ranking in organic search
results unlike social media where users
aren't actively seeking products or
Services consumers using search engines
are often ready to make a purchase the
intent driven approach makes sem
powerful tool for connecting with
potential customers who are actively
seeking relevant information ultimately
boosting a company's chances of making
sales so this was about why sem is
important now let's have have a look at
the difference between sem and
SEO so search engine marketing and
search engine optimizations play pivotal
roles in online marketing as involves
paying search engines like Google or
displaying ads and search results on the
other hand SEO does not require payments
to Google instead businesses aim to
secure a free sport in search results by
offering the most relevant content for
specific keywords sem is like a shortcut
where you pay for immediate visibility
while SEO is a long-term strategy
earning visibility organically ideally
combining both is a smart approach SEO
drives consistent traffic over time
especially at the top of the marketing
funnel while sem with its paid ads is a
cost- effective way to boost conversions
at the bottom of the funnel it's a
dynamic duo for comprehensive online
marketing strategy so this was about the
difference between search engine
marketing and search engine optimization
now let's understand how it works that
is how semm works so search engine
marketing works like a online
advertising when you search on Google
you see some results at the top with a
small ad tag those are sem ads
businesses pay to show their ads there
it's like putting up a billboard where
lots of people can see it here's how it
works first business choose a specific
words that is keywords related to what
they offer when someone searches using
these words if the business is Bid
enough money their ad can show up the
more they bid the higher the chance of
their ad gets seen imagine you have a
local bakery and you want more people to
know about your delicious cupcakes this
is where search engine marketing comes
in let's say someone is in your town is
craving for cupcakes and types yummy
cupcakes near me into Google if you have
set up sem campaign and bid on the right
keywords like yummy cupcakes your
bakery's ad may appear at the top of the
search results with a little ad tag now
picture a person seeing your ad and
thinking oh that's look tasty they click
on your ad visit your Bakery website and
maybe even place an order for cupcakes
so in this example sem helped your
bakery get noticed when someone was
actively searching for what you offer
cupcakes you paid a bit to Google but in
return you gathered a new customer it's
like putting up a sign saying hey we
have the cupcakes you're looking for
when someone is out searching for a
sweet treat now let's understand about
sem tools so search engine marketing
tools first we have is Sam Rush Sam Rush
is a tool that helps you know what
people are searching for online it tells
you about popular keywords what your
competitors are doing and how your
website is doing compared to others it's
like a map of making your website stand
out in online crowd then there is Google
ads Keyword Planner Google ads Keyword
Planner is a tool by Google that helps
you pick the best word for your online
ads if you're a baker it suggests words
like delicious cupcakes or fresh
pastries to reach more people it's like
a helper for choosing the right words to
get noticed then there is Google Trends
so Google Trends shows what popular on
the internet right now whether it's a
new dance or the latest gadget it helps
you stay updated on what people are
talking about it's like a trending watch
friend keeping you in the loop all right
now moving on to the next to topic which
is how do ad auctions work so Google
Bing and Yahoo use an auction system for
ads during every user search in the
Google ad auction various factors decide
which ad appears on the top of the
search results this includes the quality
score from Google ads Google paperclick
platform it's not just about the budget
relevance matters even if a campaign has
smaller budget it can beat a bigger one
if the content is more fitting similar
to organic rankings factors like trust
signals and web traffic also influence
who wins the ad space in Google auction
these ads go through an auction process
with each user search in Google ads
auction the ads position isn't solely
determined by the campaign's budget the
quality score earned through Google ads
plays a significant role unlike a state
forward budget race the auction plays
relevance a smaller budget can Triumph
if the ad is more relevant to the the
user search additionally organic search
factors like trust signals and web
traffic also wait in ensuring that
auction isn't solely about money but
about showing the most fitting ads to
users so this was about how ad auctions
work now let's understand sem campaign
strategy so in sem campaign strategy
first we have is keyword research so
discover what keywords people use when
searching for your product or service
for instance if you run a cupcake shop
identify terms like tasty cupcakes near
me select these keywords to connect with
potential customer actively looking for
what you
offer so next is campaign creation
establish your online advertising
campaign craft straightforward ads with
appealing language for the cupcake shop
an ad could be delicious cupcakes order
Now set a budget for how much you are
willing to pay when someone clicks on
your ad keeping it simple and engaging
to attract
attention the next is measurement and
optimization evaluate the performance of
your ads track clicks and conversions if
results aren't satisfying adjust your
ads or
keywords constantly Define your approach
based on what resonates best with your
audience to improve outcomes over
time so this was about the sem campaign
strategy so in this video we have
understood the importance of
differentiated from SEO understood how
it works discovered essential sem tools
unravel the Dynamics of AD options and
mastered effective sem campaign
strategies and with that we have come to
the end of this video If you like this
video please give it a thumbs up I hope
it really helped you all thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upscaling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set your yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here